well soon soon David you will stop being
such a little fat bastard nice hey what
is going on YouTube now as you all may
well know I travel a lot and normally
what I booked the flight I do it based
on one thing price so usually when bad
things happen I can't really complain
because you get what you pay for you buy
cheap [ __ ] you get cheap results but I
do have to say because I fly a lot I
deal with some of the most annoying [ __ ]
but there is some [ __ ] that airlines do
to us that's all that's right spirits
and Allegiant and though this video goes
to you American air you a chode flavored
juice bottle this goes out to all the
[ __ ] airlines I still have the [ __ ]
tag on my shirt
look at that that's embarrassing I'm not
gonna shoot this over again so you
already know what it is LGI baby let's
get it let's go how is it that every
time I fly with you there's a delay
let's go on what what it's like there's
somebody up there that looks at the
schedule and says be on time bucket
does Davis so have to talk up each
African was that French I don't might
evoke balls ooh yes I get it
I get it it's out of your control but
there is a certain way that you should
handle it why is it that when I ask an
attendant or the ticket person why
there's a delay I get this as a response
sir because the plane is stalled [ __ ]
no [ __ ] the [ __ ] are you telling me
information I already know I know
installed you know why cuz it's not here
don't tell me that should give me a
reason so I can better understand what's
going on I get that it's out of my
control me asking you why it's too late
it's not gonna bring it faster I just
want to know as a customer who spent
money so I have peace of mind the [ __ ]
is with the attitude I think the reason
why your life sucks Beach number two
don't even get me started with intercoms
how is it that every intercom on
American air sounds like you're talking
through a [ __ ] pillow
well we didn't when you won't like use
me I don't know it when you win win win
I can't believe you do a New Jersey I
don't understand what you're saying I
don't Reese what a million dollar
playing but you
fixa was FEMA on our microphone and how
do you get mad at me for not
understanding you when you sound like
Bane from Batman [ __ ] your flight is
delayed that are like a hostage
situation speak without it you don't
need it and can we talk about the
sitting on a plane when you know there's
no liftoff for an hour and I have you
ever had that [ __ ] when you board a
plane two hours early they shut off the
damn air and all you smelling is maybe
acid pits you total kill moon and when I
asked when you found out about this you
say right when the plane landed sir we
had some issues no I did you bored us
you evil woman and it always has to do
with some [ __ ] with the engine
malfunctioning of all things do you
really think that that is the
information you should be telling us
right before to other people fly the
most uncomfortable even technical
difficulties like what we apparently
have misplaced the engine so sit tight
we'll be right with you [ __ ]
[Music]
Bonjour [ __ ]